[Musique]
le ski alpin il ya un siècle c'est un
veston cravate avec leurs skis de fond
au pied que ces casques ou se lancent à
l'assaut des montagnes
aujourd'hui le skieur et son équipement
forment un véritable bolide qui dévalent
les pentes à 10 vitesses à couper le
souffle
c'est grâce au rebond pente que le ski
alpin fait son entrée aux olympiques en
particulier l'épreuve de descente ou la
chute verticale avoisine les 1000 m avec
intel dénivelé la gravité est l'alliée
du skieur à condition de savoir
l'exploiter d'abord en limitant les vols
planés
plus un skieur passe de temps dans les
airs plus sa trajectoire ça le rouge
avec un saut cours et gagne de précieux
mètres sont l'atterrissage se fait aussi
en douceur
[Musique]
tandis qu'un seul on augmente la force
d'impact l'énergie se perdre en sol et
le skieur ralenti
pour écourter son saut l'athlète se
replie sur lui même
ce choeur viande son vol vers le bas et
le maintien près de la piste
les virages présente un tout autre défi
car il faut changer de cap en
ralentissant le moins possible lors des
premiers jeux le chasse neige est
toujours à la mode et la posture n'est
pas très aérodynamique
très tôt les skieurs se recroqueville
mais la technique de virages reste
longtemps problématique
même le fameux style parallèle implique
encore dérapages projections de neige et
énergie gaspillée
[Musique]
aujourd'hui grâce à leur forme
parabolique laisse qui épousent les
courbes et permettent de prendre les
virages en conservant un maximum de
vitesse
ils sont aussi conçus pour amortir les
vibrations et résister à la tension
grâce à eux le ski alpin est un sport
poussé à l'extrême
quand on superpose des images de ces
deux skieuses
elles se confondent presque et leurs
chronos sont identiques au centième de
seconde près main dans la main jusqu'à
la médaille d'or
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]